if for nothing else this much is for
sure Disney will stop at nothing to try
to strike gold like they did with
Pirates of the Caribbean again with
another franchise we call that fact John
Carter or John Carter of Mars for you
purists since John Carter this time so
John Carter is set in the 1800s John
Carter is a guy he's from Virginia he
fought in the Confederate Army he's had
enough of war he's like no I'm done with
this I don't want war I don't want a
fight then he grabs him at Dalian and
says a couple words and now he's
transported to Mars a planet that as we
know it is completely desolate and has
no oxygen but for the sake of this movie
well that's just not true so on the
planet Mars you have your humanoid
aliens that have four arms like d'Oro
from Mortal Kombat and you have the
human beings who have technology and
their airships from one of the later
Final Fantasy games bad guys being led
by Jimmy McNulty from the wire so I
thought that's cool and you have a hot
chick so that is extra cool and then at
a point you're like this looks like it's
gonna be Waterworld in space that's not
cool a space planet that's a desolate
desert so I guess it's desert world in
any case you're skeptical at this point
so when John Carter was starting out oh
so like I'm not really feeling this I'm
not really into the movie that the
editing is kind of choppy it's kind of
slow then you get to Mars and you feel
pretty much exactly the same way at a
point you're like all right I see where
they're gone with this movie I can see
how this can be cool so I'll give it a
shot when you're watching the movie
you're like all right I guess this can
be entertaining for kids because adults
are gonna pick this movie apart I get
that the atmosphere and Mars a
difference with the gravity's lighter
junk Carter's not used to that so we can
jump really far and it's really cool but
when he falls he falls at the same rate
that he would fall on earth so it
doesn't really show that the gravity is
different and so you're thinking when he
lands he's gonna snap his legs but he
doesn't at that point you're like all
right not meant for me it's meant for
kids although there are some parts we're
like oh that guy just lost his head
apparently it's not meant for kids
there's this one dude just like John
Carter I'm coming for you and he charged
them and John Carter just lost his head
off in one second you're like oh whoa
that guy's been a dick for the entire
movie and now he's dead kinda like him
blade you know with that one dudes like
oh I got two hands I don't know which
one to kill you with he charges that
blade and blade just takes his zip line
and takes his head off you're like all
right well that was not a fight he's
dead now it's kind of like that only
four blade I felt it work better than
the movie ends like three different
times you're like all right this movie
let's wrap it up then the movie ends in
a way that's like I will make a sequel
if you guys
you know please and if I can describe
the movie JOHN CARTER in any way it's
like this it's kind of like Waterworld
in space meet Stargate meets some 80s
sci-fi fantasy movie like crawl but not
crawl I won't say the movies dog
there were parts that I did enjoy but I
will say it's okay but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus two days yep I
already forgot about it so your favorite
space sci-fi fantasy type movie doesn't
even have to be sci-fi fantasy sci-fi go
for it fantasy and space go for that
whatever it may be comment below let me
know and as always if you'd like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more